Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt
Mein Name ist Tim Britlaff und ich begrüße alle hier zur Ausgabe 82 und es ist mal wieder ein Freitag, diesmal Punktlandung und wir machen ein Corona-Wikli, das heißt, ich begrüße Pavel, hallo Pavel.
Hallo Tim.
Genau. Und nach drei Wochen wollen wir mal wieder,
zusammenfassen und mal zurückblicken, was denn eigentlich so passiert ist in unserer kleinen Pandemie. Die haben irgendwie so vertraut geworden ist mit der Zeit. So und ich habe auch so den Eindruck.
Ähm das Ding ist jetzt irgendwie, wie soll ich das formulieren? So ein bisschen eingepreist. Also.
Heute, heute war ähm diese Klima, dieser Klimastreik, also die große Klimademo.
Mhm. Mhm.
Überall in Deutschland, auch in Berlin. Ich bin da mal gewesen und habe mir das Geschehen mal ein wenig angeschaut.
Und äh was ich am bemerkenswertesten fand, da waren echt viele Jugendliche.
Wenig überraschend, ja. Also das, was ich der Überraschung oder nicht der bemerkenswerte Punkt, sagen wir's mal so. Bemerkenswert fand ich das, obwohl das alles im Freien stattfand, so gefühlt.
Ich würde sagen, fünfundneunzig Prozent aller Leute, die da rumliefen, Masken aufhatten.
Mhm. Ja?
Damit hätte ich jetzt nicht unbedingt gerechnet, zumal es halt auch so okay, es war ist jetzt so langsam so, na ja, also,
Sommer kann man's jetzt schon nicht mal nennen, aber ist auch noch nicht so richtig Herbst, aber es war so bewölkt und war so Wind am Start, also schon so, wo man sagen würde, ja, ist jetzt
mit so viel Wind, was soll schon passieren, aber nee, trotzdem, da war einfach so eine gewisse.
Eigendisziplin am Start, die fand ich schon ziemlich bemerkenswert und da das ja nun auch ein wenig der.
Wie soll ich sagen? Wache bewegte Teil der Gesellschaft ist, der da auf der Straße war, wo ich das mal sehen. Ähm ja, in dem Kreis,
Hasse keine Maskenschreier, sondern hast halt irgendwie Leute, die einfach zur Kenntnis genommen haben, ist halt Pandemie so.
Demonstrieren, aber muss ja jetzt auch nicht gleich total unvorsichtig sein.
Ja, ich meine, das trägt sicherlich auch noch äh gerade zur Senkung vom R äh Wert, beides Maskenregime, also wahrscheinlich schon sagen, dass wenn äh ja,
Leute gar keine Masken mehr tragen würden, ist wahrscheinlich ein Ticken höher wäre wie viel, weiß ich nicht, aber
so es könnte schon in der Größenordnung so null Komma eins auf's R machen, was einen dann wieder über eins schieben würde. Also wir sind jetzt gerade aktuell bei null Komma neun.
Ja
Was erfreulich ist.
Ja, jetzt, jetzt hast du schon auf die Zahlen umgeleitet. Äh wolltest du noch ähm noch noch noch eine Replik auf meine allgemeine Feststellung mache,
irgendwie also wieso das Verhältnis eigentlich jetzt der Gesellschaft zu zu diesem Pandemiestatus ist?
Für ja, irgendwie so wie gesagt, äh ich weiß nicht, ob du den Begriff äh kennst.
Ja, aber ich vergesse jedes Mal wiederum, wie äh wie wie es gemeint ist.
Halt irgendwie so eine Serie, wo dann irgendwann die halt immer sensationeller wurde und irgendwann haben sie dann halt den Protagonisten mit Wasserschieren, halt übern Hai äh rüberspringen lassen und
das war halt so over the top, äh dass dann irgendwie alles danach so äh da äh das kommt nur noch bergab gehen.
Und das ist sozusagen der Begriff äh.
Würde sagen, sie die Pandemie äh so ähm also irgendwie, ja, haben wir, glaube ich.
Lockt keinen mehr hinterm Ofen vor, würde ich jetzt mal so frei übersetzen.
Ja, sind äh so, äh wahrscheinlich haben wir den den Gipfel der Aufregung äh äh hinter uns.
Ja. Okay, ja das kann auch ganz gut hinhauen.
Ja, es ist so, das ist, glaube ich, das, was ich meine, mit habe ich gesagt, eingepreist, das habe ich zumindest gedacht. Also so dieses man hat das jetzt im Kopf, man man weiß, dass das da ist. Alle haben sich so gewisse Automatismen
angewohnt irgendwie. Man denkt gar nicht mehr groß drüber nach, die Maske anzuziehen, also mit Mann meine ich jetzt so die allermeisten.
In Zügen, in Supermärkten, in engen Situationen, sogar eben auf so 'ner Demo und es ist die Aufregung irgendwie gar nicht mehr wert.
Umso dramatischer natürlich, dass es jetzt diese Woche zu diesem absurden Mord gekommen ist, ja.
So ein durchgedrehter die Leute sind auch teilweise wirklich so zerstört, ne? Das ist echt unfassbar.
Also nur weil jemand darauf aufmerksam gemacht wird, dass er doch auch in der Tankstelle äh nochmal eine Maske aufsetzen soll, sich darüber so aufzuregen, gleich zum jungen Menschen äh des Lebens zu nehmen, das kann man sich irgendwie alles überhaupt nicht mehr vorstellen.
Ich mein manche sagen das ist auch struchrastischer Terrorismus aber ich würde sagen es ist auf jeden Fall ist es storastisch nämlich in dem Sinne, ich mein
Du hast, ich sage mal, unterschiedlich,
erregbare Leute und unterschiedlich erregte Leute so in einem unterschiedlich hohen Reiz Zustand und jetzt muss man schon fairerweise sagen, dass halt so
vielen Leuten 'ne Menge zugemutet worden ist.
In der Pandemie so. Und der eine kommt halt besser damit klar und der andere kommt halt
weniger gut damit klar und bei Leuten die sowieso irgendwie nicht klar kommen die kann's dann irgendwie völlig dann halt
ja soweit schieben, dass sie jetzt in dem Zustand dann plötzlich drin sind, wo sie dann irgendwie äh das
Leben von jemand anderem äh nehmen und leben anderer zerstören und ihr eigenes Leben muss man natürlich auch so
ich sag mal festhalten, ja? Also das war jetzt halt auch 'ne ziemlich ja
äh nicht nur eine eine ziemlich abscheuliche, sondern auch eine ziemlich dämliche Aktion. Aber ähm ja
Ähm wie gesagt, wenn die,
Das ist ja jetzt keine Entschuldigung sein, sondern es ist halt einfach nur eine Erklärung und mir ist das halt aufgefallen, dass allgemein eben Leute rabiater geworden äh sind. Ich auch selbst rabiater geworden äh bin und sagen auch beim
manchmal so ähm.
Ja, ich ich dann ungeduldig bin oder auch weniger tolerant äh äh bin, wenn dann äh grade im Zusammenhang mit mit Covid äh irgendwie äh dann Dinge nicht so laufen
in meiner Umgebung, dass ich mich da jetzt bedroht oder gefährdet,
äh fühle. Gut, in dem Fall glaube ich nicht, dass er sich irgendwie bedroht oder gefährdet gefühlt hat, sondern vermutlich nur irgendwie, keine Ahnung, beleidigt oder was auch immer
aber äh ja ähm,
Ich weiß nicht, ich habe da ja so ein bisschen auch meine eigene äh äh Philosophie und ich denke nicht, dass äh
der jetzt äh ja irgendwie glücklich wird äh mit der Tat und äh irgendwie da jetzt sich irgendeinen Vorteil von versprochen.
Und wenn, dann bis ich ach, mag gerne, was das für ein Vorteil sein soll.
Ja, ich persönlich versuche, meinen Ärger gar nicht so hoch kochen zu lassen. Gibt natürlich so, so, so, so Details, die mich stören, aber.
Irgendwie aus das Gefühl, man muss es jetzt auch langsam ein bisschen ausklingen lassen wie.
Alles jetzt grade so ein bisschen den Eindruck macht, als würde es langsam ausklingen.
Um das äh mal zu überprüfen, ob denn das stimmt, würde ich sagen, machen wir doch mal einen Blick in die Zahlen. Pavel.
Du verfolgst nach wie vor Risikotabelle DE. Äh alles das, was das RKI so an Zahlen, Material rauslässt.
Was lässt sich da herauslesen aus diesen.
Also es sind.
Sind halt vor allem die Inzidenzdaten äh so, die ich mir anschaue und äh versuche dann auch zu interpretieren,
und ähm man muss halt.
Immer dazu sagen und gerade auch jetzt dazu sagen, dass die Inzidenz auch nicht mehr das ist, was sie mal war, ähm beziehungsweise.
Dadurch, dass eben wir jetzt eine gewisse Impfquote erreicht haben und wahrscheinlich auch eine Immunität mindestens in Höhe der Impfquote.
Wenn man dann noch äh die,
mit durchgemachter Erkrankung äh dazu rechnet in äh sofern ja
ist jetzt 'ne aktuelle Inzidenz von 66, wie wir sie jetzt haben, grade in Deutschland,
auf Basis der in den letzten sieben Tagen veröffentlichten täglichen Zahlen, muss man mal dazu sagen. Ähm,
also sechsundsechzig ,7 ähm so Neuinfizierte in den letzten 7 Tagen je 100.000 Einwohner,
und.
Ja, R-Wert hatten wir schon gesagt. Liegt bei null Komma neun, also die Zahlen sinken jetzt seit, ja, gut zwei Wochen äh würde ich sagen, drei Wochen sogar,
Also, das ist jetzt erstmal kein irgendwie kurzer Einbruch gewesen, sondern ähm auch wenn man sich.
Zahlen dazu anguckt würde ich sagen haben wir es tatsächlich mit 'nem realen Rückgang der äh Infektionsausbreitung zu tun und nicht mit einem,
Mess oder Testakt. Ähm.
Ein bisschen können das verzerrt sein, möglicherweise durch die Reiserückkehrer, dass der Anstieg, den wir gesehen haben, äh eben auch ein bisschen durch, ja, Reiserückkehrer mit befeuert
worden ist und das jetzt möglicherweise auch nachlässt. Ähm wenn,
man jetzt in die Inzidenzen nach Altersgruppen reinschaut, ist es so, dass erstens auch in allen Altersgruppen wir einen Rückgang,
sehen können unterschiedlich stark ausgeprägt und
wir jetzt die niedrigsten Inzidenzen bei den 60 bis 79jährigen gerade haben bei einundzwanzig, aber äh ganz nah dran bei fünfundzwanzig dann äh die die achtzig Plus, also die
sag mal über 60-jährigen kann man sagen liegen so zwischen 20 und 25 von der Inzidenz, was halt,
erfreulich ist,
niedriger sein, weil äh mit der bei der Inzidenz sterben dann halt schon Leute auch in denen in den Altersgruppen ähm
Ja und die höchsten Inzidenzen haben wir,
jetzt weiter in der Altersgruppe der fünf bis Vierzehnjährigen. Da liegen sie bei hundertsechzig. Ähm.
Das ist halt äh ja, weniger schön. Ähm,
wird man wird man sehen aber auch da äh gehen die eben stark zurück und in der zweiten Gruppe die 15 bis Vierunddreißig-jährigen liegt's halt auch bei fünfundneunzig so, das heißt wir haben halt,
im Prinzip eine ganz gute Altersstaffelung jetzt bei Inzidenzen mit Ausnahme, allerdings der Null
bis Vierjährigen,
bei denen die Inzidenzen nur bei 64 liegen. Also sie liegen quasi jetzt in der in der Mitte äh irgendwo, also bei sagen Kitas scheinen gerade entweder nicht das Problem zu sein oder
es wird nicht mehr so viel getestet dort, ich weiß es nicht.
Die positiven Quote, wenn man die mal heranzieht, spricht ja im Prinzip jetzt dieselbe.
Ne? Also du meintest ja, es kann jetzt nicht nur in den Reiserückkehrern liegen, wir haben
der positiven Quote folgt und die ist ja hier so ein bisschen der klassische Bewertungsmaßstab so für den allgemeinen Verlauf der Pandemie kann man dann natürlich erst drüber diskutieren, ob das noch gilt.
Aber das ging im Prinzip seit Anfang Juli los, also gerade als äh
ähm ersten Schulferien erst so richtig eingesetzt haben nach ein, zwei Wochen, ging das hoch und es ging auch dann stret hoch und es ging auch schnell hoch und äh hat sich halt jetzt erst vor zwei Wochen gefangen
Und jetzt haben wir äh seit zwei Wochen fallende Zahlen in der Richtung
ähm die Positivquote, wo liegt die jetzt gerade? Ähm.
Bei 7,52 Prozent. Nachdem sie zwischenzeitlich auf acht Komma.
Sechs, sieben hochgeschnellt war.
Zum Vergleich in unserem niedrigsten Moment in der 25. Woche waren wir so äh bei null Komma.
Acht eins, sechsundzwanzigste Woche, um genau zu sein.
Und grundsätzlich gilt ja, man sollte unter 5 Prozent sein, damit man so in etwa die Aussage treffen kann, dass die Testzahlen halt auch eine klare, deutliche Sprache sprechen und die ähm Dunkelziffer.
Nicht mehr so hoch ist. Also ein bisschen Dunkelziffer ist jetzt sozusagen noch, aber auch nicht so in so einem megadramatischen Maße.
Warum? Warum fallen die Zahlen? Meine mit Delta.
Allerlei.
Ja, angekündigt worden, wie sehr sich denn das so äh durchsetzen könnte. Klar, die erste Antwort lautet natürlich, es werden auch nach wie vor Leute geimpft. So, aber wir haben ja jetzt auch noch nicht unbedingt die Impfzahlen erreicht, die wir gerne hätten.
Wenn man ähm.
Also dadurch, dass sich das halt hat in allen Altersgruppen äh jetzt abspielt, würde ich sagen, ist ein Indiz dafür, dass es sich äh um etwas handeln könnte, was halt auch alle betrifft.
So und da fällt einem natürlich vor allem dann erstmal das Wetter ein. Ähm,
Ja, also das führe ich jetzt auch nicht ausschließen, dass entweder das Wetter direkt oder die Verhaltensänderung, dadurch, dass es jetzt etwas kälter geworden ist äh auch einen einen Einfluss haben auf die
Ausbreitung. Ja.
Aber sonst warten wir ja eigentlich immer dem richtig guten Wetter, genau diese Eigenschaft zugeschrieben.
Naja, ähm sagt je nach also Land und Leuten äh so hat man da eben
auch die genau umgekehrten Effekte gesehen, also das ist, dass es gibt da jetzt nicht wirklich einen linearen Zusammenhang zwischen Temperatur und
ähm und Ausbreitung, äh sondern da geht's kehrt sich das zwischendurch unter Umständen mal um,
Also wenn's dann, ich sage mal, zu warm ist, plus, wie gesagt, Verhaltensänderungen,
spielen da auch eine Rolle. Also das es wurde halt beides gemessen und ähm mal was was gibt es sonst noch so von dem alle Altersgruppen,
betroffen sein könnten.
Ja gut, Schulferien sind jetzt überall beendet. Ähm alle müssen jetzt wählen. Keine Ahnung, ob das irgendeine Auswirkung hat. Ich weiß es nicht, um ehrlich zu sein.
Wie ist denn die Verteilung in den Bundesländern? Ist denn diese ähm Aktivität auch gleichmäßig auf die Bundesländer verteilt?
Hm wer nicht ganz gleichmäßig aber im Prinzip sind auch fast,
ist Rückgang in praktisch allen Bundesländern da, mal mehr, mal weniger,
glaube ich nur ein Bundesland, was knapp über eins liegt, aber der Trend ist eigentlich bei allen da und
halt ein bisschen hier und da Zeit verschoben unter Umständen, aber es gibt da jetzt niemanden grade, der jetzt so völlig komplett gegen den Trend marschiert, ja, außer na ja
Ähm ich meine, Bremen äh so.
Halt einem R-Wert von eins. So steht am schlechtesten da, ja? Und Bayern äh.
Dann,
mit ja null Komma neun sechs und einer relativ hohen äh Inzidenz von neunzig so.
In meiner Tabelle am zweitschlechtesten, aber gut und in Sachsen-Anhalt tatsächlich ist 1,01, hat aber nur eine Inzidenz von achtunddreißig.
Wiederum.
Ja. Also er wertmäßig sind die auch alle sehr nah beieinander. Da kann man jetzt eigentlich überhaupt nichts draus äh machen, ne. Bei der Inzidenz, ja.
Ne, da gehen sieht man halt auch äh so eine übliche Spreizung und äh Schleswig-Holstein und Mecklenburg-Vorpommern wie gewohnt am Ende ähm so der Tabelle.
Sie halt meistens hatten und ja.
Schauen wir doch vielleicht nochmal ähm auf die Impfzahlen, ähm um das auch noch gleich mit ähm drin zu haben, also Stand heute, vierundzwanzigster.
September. Haben wir noch gar nicht gesagt, ne? Vierundzwanzigster September, zwanzig einundzwanzig. Ähm.
Haben wir ähm ja 67,6 Prozent, die mindestens eine Impfdosis haben, dreiundsechzig Komma sieben Prozent sind vollständig geimpft.
Das ist immer alles noch nicht so viel, wie man gerne haben möchte. Also zumindest nicht so viel, wie ich gerne hätte.
Ähm aber was soll man machen? Und na ja, die Impfaktivität selber.
Deshalb nach wie vor zu wünschen übrig, aber immerhin.
Leute werden noch geimpft, ne? Wobei jetzt die Impfaktivität als solche.
Wird jetzt in zunehmendem Maße etwas äh schwierig zu bewerten äh rein jetzt an der.
Oder sagen wir mal so, der Fortschritt bei den Impfungen lässt sich derzeit an den Impfzahlen sehr weit nicht mehr so gut ablesen, weil es auch noch diese Auffrischungsimpfung, die Boosterimpfung dazukommt. Die machen zwar noch ein sehr
geringen Teil aus, aber der steigt natürlich jetzt auch mit an.
Grundsätzlich ist es so, dass die Erstimpfung, die Zweitimpfung nicht wieder eingeholt haben, nachdem die sich einmal gekreuzt haben
Das war ja eigentlich immer ein bisschen meine Hoffnung, dass dann irgendwann nochmal so ein Schub kommt, aber ähm derzeit liegen die äh in etwa gleich niedrig.
Und so ja, es gab schon jetzt nochmal einen leichten.
Aufschwung in den Gesamtimpfungen, aber das würde ich dann halt den Boosterimpfungen zuschreiben. Also jetzt nur Erstimpfung und Zweitimpfung alleine,
halten sich jetzt eher so ein bisschen die Waage, ne. Und äh die Waage heißt, dass der halt so um hunderttausend pro Tag liegen.
Erstinfo noch ein bisschen weniger zur äh Zweitimpfung liegen jetzt ungefähr so bei hunderttausend. Ja und das das halt nicht viel, ne.
Trotzdem erreicht ist erreicht, ne? Also dreiundsechzig Komma sieben Prozent vollständig geimpft ist ja äh jetzt auch. Vor allem man kann es ja auch mal ein bisschen ähm relativieren
Nicht wahr? Dies ist ja nach wie vor die Zahl, die sich auf die gesamte Bevölkerung bezieht, wenn man das jetzt mal,
hoch äh rechnet oder umrechnet auf.
Den ähm Bevölkerungsanteil, den zwölf Plus ausmacht in Deutschland, sind wir jetzt bei knapp 6undsiebzig Prozent.
Also anderen Worten, 76 Prozent aller Leute, die in Deutschland.
Äh sich theoretisch impfen lassen dürfen, die sind auch geimpft worden.
Haben mindestens, nein, nein, haben mindestens eine Impfdosis erhalten, so rum. Ne, also 76 Prozent sind zum Impfen gegangen, sagen wir es mal so.
Und äh wenn man's mal auf vollständige Impfung, da sind wir jetzt bei einundsechzig Komma sechs, äh einundsiebzig Komma äh sechs, ne, von zwölf plus.
Und Größenordnung sind sie sich das richtig, dass so ungefähr ein Prozent nicht ganz so pro Woche dazukommt.
In der Gegend müsste es glaube ich sein, also nicht ganz null acht vielleicht.
Ja nicht sehr viel mehr.
So, aber das sind so die Dimensionen. Also vielleicht, weiß ich nicht, drei Prozent im Monat oder so, können wir erwarten. Äh,
bin dabei, bei der Geschwindigkeit, wenn das jetzt nicht nicht noch weiter schneller abflacht, die Zahl der Erstimpfung.
Ja, also ich habe so den Eindruck, im allerbesten Fall erreichen wir so achtzig Prozent der Leute, die.
Theoretisch geimpft werden dürften, die sich letzten Endes auch impfen. Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, was passiert.
Den ähm unter Zwölfjährigen.
Es zeichnet sich jetzt ab, also Biotech hat es angekündigt, dass sie jetzt demnächst die Zulassung beantragen werden für, ich glaube, für fünf plus.
Fünfjährige bis ähElfjährige, also die wird noch dazukommen, sprich Kita und Grundschule, also Kita nur teilweise natürlich, aber die Grundschulen würden auf jeden Fall vollständig abgedeckt sein.
Wäre auf jeden Fall schon mal ein Schritt nach vorne.
Leider grad nicht geguckt, wie äh wie sich das jetzt bei den zwölf plus entwickelt hat. Da war ja relativ viel Impfaktivitäten. Ich schätze mal, das wird sich dann auch so ähnlich einpendeln wie über den ähm älteren auch.
Ja und dann dann sind 80 Prozent sicherlich äh zu erreichen und dann ist das wahrscheinlich so das, mit dem man so leben muss.
So und zurück auf die auf das Gesamtgeschehen.
Kann man halt sagen, okay, achtzig Prozent, das hat auf jeden Fall die Pandemie eingebremst.
Vielleicht nicht unbedingt komplett ausgebremst, aber das ist schon etwas, was man jetzt sieht, ja, also ohne diese Impfung hätte uns Delta komplett äh.
Gekillt.
Also ich denke auch, also für noch bei der Debatte, okay, was könnte jetzt der Rückgang äh äh sein und.
Das hängt natürlich auch mit den Impfungen äh zusammen. Es ist ja,
man muss natürlich auch mal gucken, es dauert ja immer eine gewisse Zeit, bis die Leute eben auch die volle Immunität entwickeln und wenn man dann jetzt auch nochmal guckt, okay, der große Impfberg ähm so.
Im Rekorde hatten wir ja so Ende Juni im Prinzip. Also im im Prinzip im Juni ist so ja äh
ist, glaube ich, am meisten insgesamt verimpft worden. Ähm.
Und da sind dann auch so die meisten sagen, haben dann Impfung gekriegt und dann kannst du ja je nach je nachdem,
was das für ein Impfstoff war, noch ein paar Wochen dauern bis da wirklich die maximale Immunität erreicht ist. Ähm.
Und das könnte dann halt auch dazu beigetragen äh haben quasi
weil es ja nicht so, wenn heute einer geimpft wird oder erst geimpft wird, passiert ja erstmal noch nichts. Äh vielleicht ist es eben auch jetzt der der Berg, der Hit irgendwie rein äh kommt, weil äh ja.
Ja gut, also der Berg ist schon schon lange eingepreist so, ne? Also man die sich äh also die große Zweitimpfwelle, das war ja im Juni,
Ne, also die meisten Erstimpfungen, die haben, also die Hauptaktivität das war, im.
Lasst mich schauen, Ende April, Anfang Mai.
Und dann äh gab's den entsprechenden Zweitimpfberg im im Juni.
Ende Juli und äh Anfang Juli. So und seitdem geht's halt dann irgendwie bergab so und das heißt, der Großteil, der da geimpft wurde, der ist halt jetzt auch.
Voll immun. Naja, jetzt ist natürlich viel Diskussion um diese Auffrischungsimpfung.
Die sind jetzt auch offiziell gesetzlich äh verankert und ab dem 1. September möglich. Das bedeutet, dass jeder, der.
Ähm sechs Monate Abstand zur ersten Impfserie hat.
Genau weiß, worauf sich das äh konkret bezieht, also ob das jetzt auf die Erstimpfung oder die Zweitimpfung sich bezieht, aber ich vermute mal, die Zweitimpf.
Impfung, die Zweitimpfung, ja.
Genau. Empfohlen ist es eben für achtzig Plus. Die sollten es auf jeden Fall machen.
Ähm aber soweit ich das gelesen habe, gibt es grundsätzlich erst mal keine Einschränkungen für bestimmte Gruppen. Das heißt, man kann im Prinzip eine Dritteimpfung ähm.
Sollte man erhalten können, wenn man sie möchte, wenn die Zweitimpfung sechs Monate her ist.
Und was sie auch gehört habe, ist, dass wenn Leute ein besonderes Anliegen haben, was weiß ich, Reisen in ein Land, wo Dritteimpfungen äh erforderlich sind. Da gibt's noch nicht so viele, aber Israel wäre so ein Kandidat. Ähm dann.
Kann man da sicherlich auch äh ja was bewirken.
Genau. Und ist auch noch die Frage, wie gut halten jetzt die einzelnen Impfstoffe? Also es gab eine Meldung.
Äh diese Impfdurchbrüche, dass ja dieser etwas schwierige Formulierung für man ist geimpft, aber kann sich trotzdem infizieren und ähm.
Gegebenenfalls halt auch einen Krankheitsausbruch haben in einem bestimmten Maße. Die sind ja an sich selten
ja? Also bei Bier und ist so derzeit äh die Rede von 675 Impfdurchbrüchen pro Million.
Pro Millionen, also nicht viel. Bei Johnson und Johnson seien es.
Meer, so in der Größenordnung von 200. Das ist ja der Impfstoff, den nur einmal verabreicht wird und ähm da würde ich auch definitiv nochmal zu einer Boosterimpfung raten.
Bin ich mir aber jetzt gerade nicht ganz so sicher, ob das generell sofort akzeptiert wird, wenn man jetzt sagt, ich will eine haben.
Ja, also soweit ich weiß, ist ähm.
Sagen, äh gibt es es läuft eine Studie, äh sagen, wie das
ist mit äh Jansen und dann Booster oder Kreuzimpfung oder wie auch immer. Sie laufen Studien, die sind,
aber wohl die Ergebnisse noch nicht da, aber alle gehen eigentlich davon aus, äh dass man sich problemlos mit irgendwas anderem hinterher
lassen können, sollte. Man weiß halt dann nur nicht, äh wirklich wie
das dann genau mit der Prozentzahl äh aussieht, aber ähm so die Erfahrung mit
in allen anderen Fällen zeigt eigentlich, dass das äh in der Regel hervorragend.
Funktioniert somit verschiedenen Impfstoffen ähm
so nacheinander äh zu impfen. Und ich glaube, äh so Jansen arbeitet auch an einem äh Booster selbst. So.
Das habe ich jetzt so in Erinnerung.
Also da wird auf jeden Fall noch was kommen und ich denke, es zeichnet sich ohnehin ab, dass wir erstens.
Grundsätzlich von einer extrem hohen Verträglichkeit ähm,
ausgehen können, wenn man es mit unterschiedlichen Impfstoffen.
Bearbeitet wird, also mit anderen Worten, ist letztlich egal, was das triggert, Hauptsache irgendwas triggert und es ist theoretisch halt oder praktisch auch bisher so gesehen worden, dass wenn man verschiedene Impfstoffe mixt, dass es.
Tendenziell eher gut ist.
Weil man verschiedene Sichtweisen quasi bekommt, auf das Virus in den Körper und der Körper dementsprechend positiv darauf reagiert, also höhere.
Höheren Schutz erzeugt, mehr Antikörperreaktion zeigt und das zeigt sich dann auch nochmal zusätzlich jetzt bei diesem Booster-Impfung, also auch die dritte Impfung.
Wird wahrscheinlich irgendwann auch einfach empfohlen sein, weil es ja nun generell, das sagen wir hier auch schon von Anfang an oder zumindest seit einiger Zeit.
Man wird sich wahrscheinlich irgendwann in seinem Leben auch nochmal,
mit Corona, mit Covid-neunzehn infizieren. So, ich, du, ja alle, weil das Ding einfach da ist und irgendwann erwischt's einen eben, wie man so eine Erkältung bekommt, wie man eine Grippe bekommen kann.
Nur die Frage ist, wie reagiert der Körper, wie äh krumm nimmt einem das der Körper, wenn's denn dann mal soweit ist,
Das hängt eben davon ab, wie gut die Immunisierung, die vorab in die Immunisierung entweder durch Impfstoffe oder mindere Infektionen ähm schon war. Wie oft hat man das schon gesehen,
hat sich der Körper schonenden Schutz aufgebaut. Und durch diese Doppelimpfung oder die einfache Impfung bei Johnson und Johnson, so dass.
Reicht.
Für die aller aller meisten Leute schon mal um die Chance auf einen schweren Verlauf und auf auf Sterben sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr niedrig zu halten,
also fast allen Fällen ist der Schutz,
dadurch schon mal ausreichend, aber es zeigt sich halt auch, nach sechs Monaten muss das wieder neu bewertet werden. Und dann macht so eine Booster-Impfung Sinn.
Und vielleicht werden wir auch irgendwann noch eine dritte äh noch eine vierte und eine noch eine fünfte Impfung sehen. Gut, ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben, aber weiß man ja heute noch nicht,
ähm und irgendwann wird man dann einfach das natürliche Coronavirus mal in die Nase bekommen und dann sagt der Körper halt so, ah ja, kenne ich schon.
Dann macht's halt dann nichts mehr aus. Und dann dann ist es halt indemisch, dann ist es halt da, dann ist es halt einfach eine Krankheit, die.
Erwischen kann und dann ist es immer noch ein Problem für Leute, die ein schwaches Immunsystem haben. Es ist immer noch ein Problem für Leute, die sehr alt sind
ist es vielleicht auch dann in wenigen Fällen auch für junge äh noch ungeimpfte Personen. Ähm.
Oder halt vor allem natürlich für die, die sich jetzt die ganze Zeit an der Impfung entzogen haben und die ist dann natürlich dann irgendwann auch voll erwischt und das halt unter Umständen mit,
noch weiter hochgefahrenen Varianten.
Vielleicht kann man sagen.
Mir grade ein so ein ganz guter Vergleich, dass äh an Corona oder Covid-19 unterimpften äh jetzt wirklich dann so was wie eine Grippe ist. Ähm.
Das heißt nicht ungefährlich, kann halt auch unangenehm werden und gerade bei älteren immer noch gefährlich äh so, auch bei Geimpften
Älteren, aber eben mit einer Gefährlichkeit, die eher vergleichbar ist, äh äh dann, mit wie wir sie von den typischen Grippeviren kennen und nicht eben
mit Faktor zehn so wie,
dass halt ja ist, wenn es auf eine ältere, ungeimpfte Bevölkerung trifft, kann man sagen, mit denen,
Da ist es eben auch so mit mit Grippeviren in der Regel, mit den mit den Stämmen ist es so, wenn die grassieren, dann ähm wird.
Halt die gesamte Bevölkerung immer im jungen Alter durch immunisiert, mehr oder weniger, wo es halt nicht viel ausmacht
und äh deswegen ist das dann auch bei den älteren nicht so, dass
normalerweise, es sei denn, es kommt dann eben irgendein neuer Virenstamm, äh der halt so anders ist, dass niemand dagegen Immunität hat dann, wie wir es jetzt bei Corona
gesehen haben, aber wenn das eben jetzt so weitergeht und wir dann alle irgendwie geimpft sind oder dass äh schon mal irgendwo äh gesehen haben, das Virus ist unser Immunsystem, das äh gesehen hat,
äh ja, dann sind eben auch neue Varianten ähm solange es da eine Kreuzimmunität gibt
eben auch äh glaube ich in ihrer Gefährlichkeit dann eher mit der Grippe vergleichbar.
Genau, es gab auch interessante Meldungen zu der Wirkung der Booster-Impfung. Also äh vor allem aus Israel, wo ja mit Bier und Tech viel ähm,
Also eigentlich nur mit Bier und Tech geimpft wird und dann eben auch sehr viel analysiert wird, haben wir ja schon tausendmal gesprochen. Da äh sind jetzt schon sehr viele Booster-Impfungen durchgeführt worden. Also Israel ist da ja äh ganz weit vorne. Mittlerweile ist es ja auch ähm
so, dass man ähm auch nicht mehr als geimpft gilt, wenn man nicht seine Boosterimpfung hat nach äh sechs Monaten Abstand,
dementsprechend, da ja alle sehr früh dort geimpft wurden im Januar, Februar, März, ging das ja schon richtig los. Hm ist die Impfaktivität da jetzt auch sehr hoch?
Also da wird jetzt wirklich ähm sehr viel geimpft. Ich schaue gleich nochmal, wie das da eigentlich grade ähm aussieht.
Auf jeden Fall gibt's aber Zahlen zu den zu den Wirkungen und da ist es halt so, dass bei,
Leuten äh im Altersbereich 65 plus, die durch die Booster-Impfung nochmal ein Elffacher Schutz erzeugt wird. Das bezieht sich also auf eine,
die Bildung von neutralisierenden Antikörper, also hat man sozusagen elfmal so viel Antikörper auf einmal, als man vorher hatte.
Bei achtzehn äh bis fünfundfünfzig ähm ist es immerhin noch so Faktor fünf. Also.
Älteren haben mehr, weil sie halt weniger Antikörper haben, so also das ist sozusagen, ne?
Ähm da hilft es also dann auch extrem viel und von daher ist auch sehr nachvollziehbar, warum wir auch in Deutschland schon diese Empfehlung haben. Gibt auch,
ähnliche Zahlen von moderner, das hat jetzt, kommt jetzt nicht aus Israel und das ist auch noch, glaube ich, ein bisschen anderer Versuchsaufbau, deswegen jetzt nicht direkt zu vergleichen, aber die sprechen
eben von bis zu 42-facher neutralisierenden Antikörper gegen gegen Delta, ne,
Ja und grundsätzlich ist so also dieser kurze Impfabstand, den man in Israel hat mit den drei Wochen, war wohl nicht so gut, umso mehr zahlt man sich da lässt, umso,
ist es da auch.
Also wir könnten natürlich jetzt auch Glück gehabt haben, dadurch, dass bei uns der Impfstoff knapp war und man den Abstand zu zweidimpfung dann äh äh so lang gesetzt hat,
könnte das wirklich vielleicht sich als Glücksfall erwiesen haben, dass das eben
auch zu einer besseren oder höheren Immunisierung geführt hat und dass wir jetzt sage mal auch noch besser geschützt sind, als jetzt äh die Leute in Israel, wenn die
ähm ich sage mal Anfang Januar und äh Anfang Februar äh ihre zweite äh Impfung bekommen haben, dann äh ja, sieht das halt anders aus während bei uns
uns jetzt vielleicht die Verschiebung jetzt zumindest dann
als Verschiebung oder die, ja, die andere Situation als in Israel, sage ich mal. Ja, uns jetzt zugute kommt grade.
Ja, also wenn man jetzt äh nach äh Basisimpfungen geht, also ohne diese Booster Impfung sind wir mittlerweile auch so äh aufm ähnlichen Level wie Israel.
Prozentual, also da ist der Unterschied jetzt nur noch wenige Prozent. Das finde ich schon mal ganz gut.
Und äh ja, man kann nur hoffen, dass dann auch mit dem Booster im entsprechend weitergeht.
Stellt sich natürlich die Frage, gibt's überhaupt genug Impfstoff dafür und die Debatte hat man ja dann hier auch, so kam auch in den Kommentaren letzte Mal auf.
Als ich gesagt habe, so, ja hiermpfung, gib her,
Es ist natürlich insgesamt noch viel zu wenig Impfstoff für die ganze Welt da, aber die Kapazitäten werden zumindest hochgefahren.
Und es sind jetzt zwei neue Fabriken für Bier und Technik in Deutschland zugelassen worden.
Wohl demnächst in Betrieb gehen, denn sie wollen noch in diesem Jahr 50 Millionen Dosis Dosen zusätzlich ähm raushauen. Ähm.
Zahl, was die so an sich an Jahresproduktion haben sollen, ist mir nicht ganz klar, aber wenn sie jetzt quasi noch im letzten Drittel fünfzig Millionen machen, würde ich halt mal so die Kapazität auf ungefähr 200 Millionen pro Jahr schätzen. So, das.
Zusätzliche Kapazität.
Ja, mit anderen Worten, das wird ähm ordentlich hochgefahren und kann nur hoffen, dass über diese ganzen Hilfsprogramme jetzt genug Impfstoff auch in alle Welt geht.
Denn na ja, wir wissen ja alle, nur hier in Deutschland oder Europa geimpft zu sein. Allein hilft ähm uns auch nur sehr begrenzt, also es hilft uns natürlich jetzt erstmal.
Dabei überhaupt geschützt zu sein, äh bis man halt wirklich Maßnahmen.
Wirklich komplett sein lassen kann und da nicht mehr drüber nachdenken muss, dazu brauchen wir auch einfach einen stark stärkeren Rückgang,
der Pandemie weltweit und das bedeutet natürlich auch vor allem ärmere Länder, ähm die sich jetzt nicht so äh die Premiumpreise leisten können, müssen hier mit entsprechenden Impfdosen versorgt werden.
Auch wenn man ein Gefühl ist, dass das jetzt im Prinzip alles anrollt und doch stattfinden wird.
Ja und ich meine, weltweit sind die Zahlen jetzt grade auch im sinken, so langsam. Äh,
Aber gut, das waren sie vorher auch immer, also es sind jetzt äh ja, aber das nur generell und ja, überhaupt äh vielleicht, weiß ich nicht, haben wir noch die die Zahlen äh äh kurz ab,
schließen, äh so mitm äh kurzen Streifen auch durch die Welt, also UK und USA sind so, äh was die Inzidenzen äh angeht,
eher so ja fast äh nicht ganz beim Zehnfachen von Deutschland, aber äh ja, die sind auf jeden Fall ganz ganz oben und
ähm.
Du bist jetzt fast bei Inzidenz oder wo bist du jetzt?
Weil genau, bei Inzidenzen, also sieben Tage äh Incidenzen jetzt und ähm ja, dann irgendwie mit mit einigen,
Abstand gut kriechen ja eigentlich sind dann die ganzen europäischen Länder sind dann schon.
Fast die Hälfte runter, also mit Österreich, Schweiz ein bisschen vorne hier gerade in meiner Auswahl.
Belgien. Ähm.
Ja und dann unter Deutschland liegen aber halt auch nochmal Haufen Länder, so Finnland, Schweden und Italien, Dänemark, Spanien, Tschechien.
Und Polen auch, da ist auch nicht viel los, also es ist vielleicht auch ganz gut für Deutschland, wenn so die Nachbarländer ähm ja zumindest die östlichen äh dann,
da nicht viel los ist, das hilft natürlich auch.
War jetzt vor ein paar Tagen war ich mal ähm für zwei Tage in Madrid.
Fand ich da mal ganz interessant zu sehen so, aha, okay, wie geht denn jetzt eigentlich so ähm das Ausland so damit um? Vorher war ich auch nochmal kurz in Prag.
Hatte ich dann wiederum das Gefühl, dass da findet irgendwie, also da ist die Pandemie gerade gar nicht da oder vielleicht war sie es auch noch nie
Da hat sich irgendwie keiner so richtig für für Impfausweise interessiert bei Veranstaltungen und ähm ja generell gab's irgendwie keine nennenswerten Restaurationen.
Ich so den Eindruck, in Spanien wiederum sah das ganz anders aus.
Naja, also ich bin Tschechien, ich war auch in,
Prag, also schon, ich sage mal, in allen Amtsstuben und äh Läden eigentlich schon Maskenpflicht überall und das habe halt auch Leute äh also Masken wurden viel getragen,
so, war mein Eindruck auch in Tschechien, aber ansonsten, ja, äh so war's das, glaube ich, auch schon an an Maßnahmen, so die ich gesehen habe.
Ja, also in Spanien war es so.
Ja, also auch da reichen jetzt zwei Tage. Äh ich hatte da auch einfach zu tun und ähm konnte mir jetzt kein umfassendes Bild machen, aber was ich bemerkenswert fand, ist, ich musste dann halt bei der Einreise
online, also ich bin natürlich geflogen, ähm musste mein erster Flug nach seit, ich weiß nicht, über zwei Jahren.
Ähm musste bei der Einreise,
Einen QR-Code erzeugen, in dem ich äh die äh erforderlichen Dokumente hochgeladen habe. Das erforderliche Dokument war im wesentlichen, in dem Fall dann einfach mein Impf.
Nachweis.
Dieses EU-PDF, dieses komische Ding, wie man's beim Abo-Ticker bekommt, ne, oder mittlerweile halt auch im Impfzentrum, so was man so schön äh.
Vier ist, aber dafür gedacht ist auf A sechs zusammengefaltet zu werden, wo eben sehr QDR-Code drauf ist. Das lädt man da hoch, das kennt das System dann irgendwie automatisch, überprüft irgendwie den Namen. Ich hatte dann irgendwie den Namen falsch geschrieben, hat er gleich gemerkt.
Ja und dann ähm erhält man einen Travel Health.
Was weiß ich, Zertifikat, QR-Code.
Den ich äh noch mit dabei haben musste und bei der Einreise wurde der dann auch nochmal am Flughafen, bevor ich überhaupt zu meinem Gepäck kam.
Flugzeug verlassen, bin da durch den Flughafen gelatscht und dann gab's halt irgendwie so eine Barriere und dann so, ja hier bitte mal einmal diesen QR-Code zeigen.
Und der wurde dann gescannt nochmal.
Ja. Aber äh sagen nix, Koffpass App äh EU kompatibel oder.
Na ja, das ist ja im Prinzip der selbe.
Aber sie haben nicht nur also sie haben nicht meinen Impfpass gecheckt, sondern sie haben im Vorfeld schon meinen Impfpass gecheckt und dass sie ihn gecheckt haben, das wiederum noch mal mit einem anderen QR-Code.
Dokumentiert,
Ich vermute mal, in dem Zusammenhang war das dann auch mit meiner Reise. Ich musste dann so Formulare und fünfseitiges Formular ausfüllen, mit welchem Flugzeug ich fliege, pipapo, also nochmal so persönliche Daten en masse,
und alles Mögliche bestätigen, dass ich irgendwie in kein bösen Ländern war und so weiter, so das Übliche. Und dieses Formular konnte ich,
Ja und ich musste noch meinen Sitzplatz angeben im Flugzeug. Also das war alles in dieser Information enthalten. Und dass ich dieses Formular,
vollständig ausgefüllt habe und mein Impfzertifikat hochgeladen wurde, das wurde mir mit diesem QR-Code dann wiederum bestätigt, den ich dabei hatte. So und den musste ich dann halt nochmal vorzeigen. Der wurde dann gescannt und das war dann aber auch okay. Das war dann einfach piep und geh weiter so. Aber,
Präsenz dieser.
Ähm Checkplätze war enorm, also in diesem Flughafen, ich habe so aus meinem Augenwinkel heraus so allein so zehn, zwanzig solche Stationen gesehen.
Also das wurde da sehr ernst genommen. Danach war dann aber auch gut. So und in der Stadt ja, ist äh immer noch sehr viel mehr Mastendisziplin.
Also ich hatte so den Eindruck, Spanien ist da gut unterwegs.
Mhm. Und aufm Rückflug.
Nüscht, weil da Deutschland, ne?
Hier kann man einfach so rein.
Klar.
Ja.
Von daher interessante Erfahrung.
Mehr Internationales kann ich jetzt auch nicht berichten, meine Reiseaktivität hat jetzt gerade erst begonnen und ich fahre eigentlich im Wesentlichen in Deutschland äh umher und darüber wissen wir ja nun eigentlich schon alles.
Ja ähm.
Wer sich natürlich jetzt die Frage, welche Maßnahmen sind jetzt eigentlich auf Vogue? Und wir haben jetzt in den letzten Wochen hier sehr viel Diskussionen gehabt rund um drei G, zwei G, zwei G plus Pipapo
denn selbst wenn sich jetzt für viele
Dinge normalisiert haben oder vielleicht auch nie den Bereich der Normalität verlassen haben, was so bestimmte Geschäftsbereiche, Industrie et cetera und so weiter betrifft.
Gibt's natürlich immer noch einen Bereich, der enorm betroffen ist und das ist halt Veranstaltungen aller Art.
Und da ich ja äh gerne zum Fußball gehe, verfolge ich die Diskussion da sehr lebhaft, was da jetzt gerade alles so beschlossen wird. Und jetzt gab's gerade jüngst so verschiedene Maßnahmen
die äh Veranstaltern die Möglichkeit geben soll, diese Stadien wieder voll zu bekommen. Das bezieht sich natürlich jetzt nicht nur auf Fußball, sondern bezieht sich auch auf Clubs, auf Konzerte, äh andere Sportveranstaltungen natürlich, weil es gab verschiedene Limitierungen, so äh,
gerade im Fußballbereich war es so generell ja Stadion maximal halbvoll und irgendwie alles mit drei G.
Das ist jetzt ein bisschen aufgeweicht worden. Jetzt gibt's im Prinzip in den meisten Bundesländern so die Ansage, na ja, wenn ihr 2G macht, dann könnt ihr auch das Stadion wieder vollmachen.
Sprich nur getestet, aber ungeimpft,
reicht nicht, muss man nachgewiesene Infektion haben, also in irgendeiner Form schon mal richtig Virus Kontakt gehabt haben, um so eine Grundimmunität zu haben. Das ist dann so die Voraussetzung und dann darf auch wieder alles voll sein. Jetzt wissen wir natürlich, dass bei Geimpften.
Trotzdem Infektion durchlaufen können, ja? Das ist halt jetzt so der Kompromiss, den man jetzt eingeht, ist.
Ja okay, wir wissen, dass wir das nicht komplett aufhalten können, aber wir wir wollen zumindest eine Situation haben, in der nicht die vulnerrabelsten direkt betroffen sind.
Natürlich jetzt jenseits der Inzidenz sehr viel mehr die Situation in den Krankenhäusern,
in den Mittelpunkt kommt, da sollten wir vielleicht auch nochmal was zu sagen. Was aber jetzt interessant ist, ist dass es natürlich wieder keine einheitliche Regelung gibt in Deutschland, sondern jedes Bundesland macht natürlich jetzt wieder seinen eigenen Kram.
Bundesregierung gibt's glaube ich auch gerade gar nicht so richtig. Wir haben jetzt äh Wahlen in zwei Tagen. Ähm.
Ja, nee, die gibt's noch. Die ist noch munter am am Wirken.
Keine einheitliche Regelung für diesen zwei G,
so, ne? Und das wäre ja äh schon mal wieder ganz äh äh hilfreich gewesen, einfach um da auch eine Chancengleichheit zu schaffen. Auch wenn ich verstehen kann, dass man sowas in gewisser Hinsicht auch regional lösen will. In Berlin
dann eben die Ansage, ja okay, wir machen jetzt hier auch zwei G, dann dürft ihr auch das Stadion vollkriegen. Nur, dass jetzt die Vereine das nicht annehmen, warum?
Wie diese Vereine sagen, diese zwei gierige so ist, dass das eben für alle gilt.
Also nicht nur für die Zuschauer.
Sondern eben auch für alle Mitarbeiter aller Unternehmen, die da arbeiten, Fernseh, Berichterstattung, Fußballspieler, die eigene Mannschaft, die andere Mannschaft.
Auf der anderen Seite, so die Argumentation.
Gibt es aber keine Auskunftspflicht, weil das ja alles Gesundheitsdaten sind. Ja, das heißt, Arbeitgeber dürfen noch nicht mal ihre Arbeitnehmer.
Ähm befragen, ob sie denn geimpft sind, weil ist ja geheim und schon gar nicht dürfen sie andere Unternehmen.
Befragen, wie denn das so mit ihren Mitarbeitern ist, die da so ankommen.
Sie können diese Informationen im Vorfeld überhaupt nicht generieren und von daher könnten sie halt auch nicht garantieren, dass sie ein 2G Everywhere durchsetzen können.
Das ist natürlich jetzt ein totales Dilemma.
Zumindest ist die Regelung in Berlin so. Offensichtlich ist in anderen Städten anders, dass wenn Stadien das trennen können, dann machen sie das eben für die Zuschauer, machen sie's halt so oder auf der einen Tribüne machen sie es so, auf der anderen Tribüne machen sie es so
So eine Unterscheidung gibt's aber zum Beispiel in Berlin nicht und das führte eben dazu, dass diese Regelungen überhaupt nicht äh angenommen wird.
Tja.
Dass es äh mal wieder so eine so eine Definitionslücke, ne? Und die Frage ist natürlich jetzt auch, was will man eigentlich? Will man.
Also was ist der Sinn und Zweck? So, auf der einen Seite sollen natürlich soll die Veranstaltungsbranche wieder in die Lage versetzt werden.
Zu arbeiten. Ja, die sind im Prinzip ja seit fast zwei Jahren lahmgelegt und die sind auch so sehr geschädigt, denn selbst wenn sie die Zeit überlebt haben, dass sich dieser.
Dass dass sich diese eingeschränkte Zustand ich würde mal meinen bestenfalls im nächsten Frühjahr.
Auflösen kann. Das bedeutet, dass es überhaupt keinen nennenswerten Einschränkungen mehr gibt, die den Ablauf.
Ähm generell ermöglichen oder zumindest in einem finanzierbaren Rahmen ermöglichen und dass auch die Branche eine Chance gehabt hat.
Personal zu bekommen, weil genauso wie die Gastronomie leidet die Veranstaltungsbranche schlicht darunter, dass viele Leute einfach nicht haben arbeiten können im letzten anderthalb Jahr, dass es keine entsprechenden,
ähm,
Absicherungen gab, ja, schon gar nicht für so Hilfstätigkeiten, wie Ordner oder so etwas und dass die sich dann gesagt haben, naja, also wenn ich jetzt nicht regelmäßig hier,
im Sport arbeiten kann oder bei anderen Veranstaltungen, dann muss ich mir halt was anderes suchen und dahaben sie sich was anderes gesucht und vermutlich auch gefunden. Und kommen natürlich jetzt nicht beim ersten Ruf.
Somit hör mal, wir könnten mal wieder ein paar Leute gebrauchen. Kommen sie ja nicht gleich wieder aus ihren Ecken gekrabbelt. Ne, weil sie ja auch
wissen, dass, wenn sie jetzt da reinwechseln, selbst wenn sie's theoretisch besser bezahlt wäre, was wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal ist, kann es ja auch durchaus sein, dass jetzt im Winter, was weiß ich jetzt nochmal, eine viereinhalbte Welle kommt und dann geht das wieder flöten.
Also das wird noch lange dauern.
Ja.
Plus man ich weiß nicht, wie krass es bei uns ist im Verhältnis zur USA, aber da ist es äh in ganz vielen Dienstleistungsbereichen jetzt so.
Dass die Leute einfach nicht zurückkommen. So und da hat irgendwie hier Luis Rossmann, ja, ich weiß nicht, ob der,
was sagt ihr Reparaturbude da, der äh bei Apple äh auch herzieht gerne und,
ähm ja, der äh hat das halt ganz gut beschrieben, was da halt äh passiert,
ähm vor allen Dingen äh gut, wo er dann auch,
wahrscheinlich mit ein bisschen, ja, äh, fast unverholener Schadenfreude schilderte
dass in den USA jetzt in den reichen Viertel gerade vor allem viele der Salons und also dass die Reichen
grade einfach keine Friseur oder Maniküre oder was auch immer Termine kriegen, weil halt
die Leute dann ja in der in der Pandemie ihre Jobs aufgegeben äh beziehungsweise gekündigt wurden,
dann gemerkt haben, oh, so was wie Jobsicherheit habe ich ja gar nicht. Und dann angefangen haben, zum Beispiel als Friseur oder so Hausbesuche zu machen,
und festgestellt haben, dass sie dabei irgendwie dreimal so viel Geld verdienen, äh dieselbe Jobsicherheit äh haben, aber eben nicht zu irgendwelchen, ja.
Niedriglöhnen,
arbeiten äh müssen so. Und deswegen haben halt jetzt äh wohl ganz, ganz viele Läden äh Probleme, die super reichen,
dagegen machen ist dann so, die dann wirklich jemanden wollen. Die haben dann ähm sagen, ihr
ihren Friseur auf Retainer. Das heißt, der kriegt dann so 3000 Dollar im Monat nur dafür bezahlt, dass er sofort kommt.
Wenn er äh.
So lösen sie Superreichen ist, aber so die die halbreichen irgendwie grade ja kriegen gerade keine Friseur und Manikürtermine
in den USA gut Plus, was natürlich richtig, ich meine, das das sehen wir hier ja auch, das haben wir überall, das.
Mit vielen anderen Dingen zusammen, aber
ja ganze plötzliche Knappheit an allen möglichen Waren und Produkten so quer äh fällt
ein. Ich persönlich war davon jetzt irgendwie noch nicht betroffen, aber ich kaufe auch nicht so viel äh äh Kram ein. Ich habe eigentlich alles. Ähm,
aber äh ja, ich ich hörte, dass hm irgendwie von
Haushaltsgeräten und wenn jetzt eine Küche brauchst oder so
empfiehlt Ikea den Kauf über Monate zu strecken, damit du irgendwie auch alle Teile dann zusammen äh kriegst und also ja Spielwarenläden und und und
Aber gut, äh wie gesagt, hast du da schon was von gemerkt?
Wovon gemerkt?
Irgendwie äh ganz viele Dinge nicht zu kaufen äh sind. Angeblich.
Nein.
Haushaltsgeräte zum Beispiel oder äh andere Dinge äh.
Ich kann keinen Mangel an Verfügbarkeit feststellen bei dem, was ich jetzt so an Bedarf habe, aber mein Bedarf ist, glaube ich, auch sehr überschaubar. Also ich.
Aber die Presse ist jedenfalls auch voll davon, äh dass gegen China und äh wie Rohstoffen und also äh lief auch so ein bisschen unter dem Thema Peek Kapitalismus.
Ja gut, ich meine, extrem ist es natürlich gerade in Großbritannien, wegen des Brexit. Ähm grundsätzlich gab's wohl auch in äh,
in Europa wohl so einen gewissen äh so einen Rückgang an Lastwagenfahrern, aber niemand hat's halt so hart getroffen wie Großbritannien, weil da sind die Leute ja nicht nur wegen der Pandemie weggerannt, sondern in dem Moment, wo Pandemie war,
Haben sie äh den Beschluss dann durchgezogen, den sie ohnehin schon für sich gefällt hatten, dass sie nämlich jetzt in Großbritannien keine Zukunft mehr sehen und denen fehlen halt jetzt irgendwie.
100.000 Lastwagenfahrer und kriegen halt derzeit überhaupt nichts. Transportiert. Es fing erstmal äh an mit ausgefallenen Milchshakes bei McDonald's.
Und ähm mittlerweile muss müssen die britischen Unternehmen im Ausland ihre Läden äh dicht machen, so Marks und Spencers in Paris
diese Kaufhausfilialen müssen sie jetzt schließen, weil sie einfach gar nichts mehr gefordert bekommen, aber was noch viel schlimmer ist, ist, dass einfach die Supermärkte leer sind
äh also nicht vollständig leer sind, sondern es gibt halt irgendwie nichts Frisches mehr, so frisches Gemüse, frisches Obst, das ist halt irgendwie alles totale Mangelware, äh entsprechend ist halt alles nur noch voll mit,
Fertig essen und jetzt äh seit dieser Woche.
Auch das Benzin knapp, kriegen jetzt ihre Tankstellen nicht mehr ordentlich beliefert und das wird natürlich dann.
Dominoeffekt sein, aber jetzt sind wir schon fast in der Brexit-Sendung, das mache ich dann mit dem John demnächst mal wieder. Da passiert gerade so einiges, aber äh letztlich war die Pandemie auch so ein Auslöser,
dass die Leute sich halt gesagt haben, so also zwei Sachen auf einmal.
Das jetzt ein bisschen zu viel so und ich muss jetzt sowieso im Lockdown bin ich äh lieber mal in meinem Heimatland. Theoretisch hätten sie auch noch alle wiederkommen, aber wegen Brexit kommt halt auch keiner mehr wieder.
Insofern haben wir auch einen gewissen Rückfluss an Personal wiederum gehabt, sodass es, glaube ich, alles in äh in der EU zumindest jetzt keine nennenswerten Auswirkungen gehabt hat.
Na ja. Auf jeden Fall.
Ist es die Frage, wie diese Maßnahmen jetzt so sich so weiter äh entwickeln? Jetzt haben wir natürlich fallende Inzidenzen und es stellt sich immer wieder die Frage, welche Maßnahmen sind denn jetzt noch die Richtigen? Und wir werden.
Also ich bin schon ganz froh, dass wir nicht so eine krasse.
Diskussion haben, wie es im Februar, als es noch im im Lockdown hieß, so, oh, jetzt muss aber endlich mal alles ein Ende finden.
Ja, also jetzt, wo eigentlich langsam auch alles ein Ende findet.
Schreien immerhin nicht alle danach, dass es jetzt langsam ein Ende finden muss, also bestimmte Sachen halten sich irgendwie, ne, über Masken tragen, haben wir ja schon genug gesprochen und das ist, glaube ich, ein Vorteil jetzt, weil dieser,
Herbst und und und der Winter, da müssen wir schon nochmal so eine Grunddisziplin an den Tag legen und ähm ne, vielleicht noch eine dritte Impfung abholen
dann bin ich eigentlich relativ zuversichtlich, da haben wir ja auch schon mal drüber gesprochen,
das jetzt gemeinsam, also dass die Zahlen von Geimpften plus Leuten, die sich's eingefangen haben, inklusive der Dunkelziffer, so über den Winter
das Frühjahr hinweg dann schon wirklich zu so einer Sättigung reichen, wo man sagen kann, okay, es gibt noch eine Krankheit, die Covid-19 HS heißt.
Aber sie wird uns gesamtgesellschaftlich nicht mehr jetzt so aus der Spur bringen, wie ist das äh in den zwei Jahren davor geschehen ist.
Ich meine
was so Prognosen äh angeht. Ich weiß nicht, ob wir da auch noch ein Teil haben oder ob wir da jetzt irgendwie nochmal zumindest ganz, ganz kurz äh zwei Sätze drüber verlieren, äh so richtig,
also.
Schlagzeile war oder so Modellierwissen irgendwie äh gerade auch nicht so richtig, wo es hingeht. Ähm also es ist
alles möglich im Moment. Äh gerade es ist alles offen. Ähm,
Aber es spricht natürlich einiges dafür, dass im im Herbst und Winter
noch was kommen wird, aber äh wie viel da kommt und ob da wirklich was äh kommt, das kann im Moment äh gerade keiner sagen, ist mein Eindruck, hast du was anderes gesehen?
Nee, ich sehe auch äh keine wirklichen klaren Prognosen. Ich meine,
Das ist halt so eine so eine schwierige Gemengelage jetzt auch, weil äh dem Moment, wo die Impfung.
Nur bei 20, 30, 40 Prozent war, war klar, dass das alles noch keine Auswirkung hat.
Jetzt sind die Zahlen zwar nicht da, wo wir sie haben wollen. Also Christian Drosten sagt ja, neunzig Prozent zumindest bei den alten Wärmen ganz gut so. Ähm.
Und wir wissen ja auch nicht, wie sich das im Variantengeschehen,
so weiterentwickelt. Ja, es wird ja äh immer mal wieder gibt's so eine so eine Variante Déjur, die ähm so hochge ähm,
und dann heißt es ja hier C zwölf und irgendwie war wieder alles total infektiös und haste nicht gesehen, nur hat sich halt,
bei den ganzen Varianten auch schon öfter gezeigt, nur weil jetzt grade
wieder eine Variante aufm Markt ist, die ganz viele Mutationen äh hat, bedeutet das nicht zwangsläufig, dass die sich auch hier durchsetzt.
Wir haben ja bestimmte Varianten hier so nie gesehen, ja? Also diese P1-Variante, die Südamerika terrorisiert hat, die hat's hier, glaube ich, bis Tirol mal kurz geschafft, aber ansonsten keine nennenswerte Dominanz gehabt und Ähnliches ist auch mit dieser Südafrika.
Variante, ja? Also die hat ja hier keine Wirkung gehabt, während Delta aus Indien halt voll reingerauscht ist über über UK und wir wissen alle nicht,
wo jetzt ähm das nächste Ding herkommt und ob.
Virus nicht doch in der Lage ist, nochmal irgendeine Immunitätshürde zu zu überspringen. Das lässt sich einfach auch überhaupt nicht.
Sagen. Und dazu kommt natürlich in Deutschland jetzt auch noch, dass wir auch gar nicht wissen, was wir jetzt für eine Regierung haben werden und wie lange es auch nur dauert, eine zu bekommen. Und.
Wie diese äh politische Sicht aufstellen wird.
Also alles ist offen.
Alles ist offen.
Aber ich, ja, aber wahrscheinlich ja schon richtig sachs, wir werden uns schon noch mal ein bisschen in Acht nehmen müssen im Herbst. Auch wenn es KI empfiehlt ja jetzt auch gleich
sagen mit dem Booster dann auch nochmal 'ne Grippeimpfung mitzunehmen, wenn man schon da ist weil
könnte natürlich jetzt auch kommen, dass das dadurch, dass halt jetzt die äh normalen Grippewellen irgendwie nicht durchgerauscht sind, wenn wir jetzt halt auch wieder sagen
Normalbetrieb fahren und ohne Masken, dann könnte es halt sein, dass uns jetzt dann auch nochmal die Grippe wellen äh äh ganz schön beuteln äh äh.
Weil äh die jetzt irgendwie Zeit hatten oder vielleicht auch nicht äh mal sehen, aber das RKI empfiehlt jedenfalls gleich die Grippeimpfung mitzunehmen.
Nicht nur das RKI vor allem die Stiko empfiehlt das und.
Äh meinte ich auch äh nicht.
Finde ich an der Stelle auch ganz wichtig, weil ähm wir wissen ja, wenn die Stiko nicht dafür ist, dann gibt's gleich wieder Diskussionen. Nee, das war eine eine Empfehlung tatsächlich von der STIKO und ja, ich hoffe,
Das gibt's dann auch bald. Also, her mit dem Booster Grippe Kombiimpfung. Die hätte ich gerne. Einmal dann bitte. So, paar Kleinigkeiten vielleicht noch, die mir so im Weg gelaufen sind, die morgen vielleicht mal kurz ansprechen sollte.
Also in Berlin zum Beispiel ist es jetzt auch so, dass.
Ähm ein Impfausweis nicht mehr reicht zum Nachweis einer Impfung, also dieser scanbare Impfausweis, der ist jetzt Pflicht.
Bin mir nicht ganz so sicher, wie es in anderen Ländern ist, aber was ich dann ganz interessant finde, ist, die mangelnde Bereitschaft zu scannen.
Weiß ja nicht, wie du das so erlebt hast, aber ich.
Ja, ja.
Sehr unterschiedliche Sachen, also von äh.
Ich im Restaurant wird mal kurz gefragt, ob man geimpft ist, aber auch an Stellen äh schon wieder Stadionsituation, dann hast du so wie die eine Schlange, da steht tatsächlich immer mit dem Smartphone und scannt die Dinger an einer anderen Schlange,
steht jemand ohne Smartphones, scannt die nicht, sondern das sind dann so diese diese App-Scroller, weißt du, die dann irgendwie so auf deinem Telefon machen.
Deswegen habe ich mir jetzt auch meinen äh Impfausweis, meinen QR-Code einfach ausgedruckt und laminiert. Und äh zeige jetzt immer den zuerst.
Um sie sozusagen zu zwingen, hier eine digitale Lösung auch durchzuführen. Ähm gut, das dann unter Umständen zu meinem eigenen Nachteil, aber so läuft es dann eben.
Das finde ich aber auf jeden Fall schon mal ganz gut.
Was auch noch interessant war, es gab äh eine Meldung, dass Forscher von Schutzwänden abraten. Das ist ja nun auch etwas, was überall noch zu finden ist, ne, an Kassen.
So weiter und auch so als Trennelemente in Kantinen ähm.
Du weißt, was ich meine. Diese ganzen Plexiglaswände, die überall äh sind und die ja eigentlich noch aus dem aus der Anfangszeit stammen.
Als noch überhaupt nicht klar war, wie dieses Virus sich wirklich überträgt und man vor allem noch davon ausgegangen ist, dass Tröpfcheninfektionen jetzt ein besonderes Problem ist.
Äh ja die Plexiglasindustrie äh äh ist auch hat auch riesige riesiges Wachstum eingefahren.
A hätte man mal investieren sollen.
Mhm, mhm.
Und jetzt stellt sich raus, dass sie sogar äh nicht nur nichts nützen, sondern unter Umständen auch noch schädlich sein können, weil sie,
irgendwie Luftströme behindern und sagen höhere Virenkonzentrationen,
beiden Seiten der Wand äh äh länger festhalten äh äh können unter Umständen so äh jedenfalls äh das Ergebnis dieser Studie und
Ja, ich glaube dem erstmal, also es ist.
Wirkt ähm ja äh plausibel würde ich sagen. Vor allen Dingen, wenn die Leute Masken tragen auch noch, dann macht's halt machen die Dinger halt,
noch weniger Sinn äh als also ja, ja und.
Insofern äh ja nicht nicht in Trennwände investieren, beziehungsweise äh.
Ja, außerdem ähm wird sie auch demnächst noch was ändern, weil jetzt der Staat nicht mehr bereit ist, äh finanzielle Unterstützung für Quarantäne, also Arbeitsausfall zu zahlen ab 1. November allerdings auch erst.
Wenn man äh ungeimpft ist und in Quarantäne muss, dann wird nicht mehr bezahlt. Ähm auch da erhöht sich jetzt der Druck.
Auf Leute, die sich nicht geimpft haben,
Ich freue mich ja auch, wenn ich wie lange manche Leute das noch durchhalten wollen jetzt irgendwie. Also es gibt ja immer noch viele Leute, muss man sagen, ich habe jetzt so ein paar Zeitungsberichte gesehen, weil natürlich jetzt immer mehr Journalisten loslaufen und dann
Leute befragen so, ah okay, ihr seid heute erst beim Impfzentrum aufgetaucht oder ihr habt jetzt hier diese mobile Impf äh Situation wahrgenommen, warum kommt ihr denn jetzt erst?
Da kommt wirklich ah die Arbeit, abenteuerlichsten Stories, also nicht unbedingt jetzt erfunden, sondern so, wo man sich denkt so.
Ah okay, was weiß ich so. Ja, am Anfang hatte ich noch so meine Zweifel und dann habe ich mich einfach eingesperrt und dann habe ich habe ich irgendwie nicht mehr so richtig drüber nachgedacht.
Oder ich bin umgeben von Impfgegnern und irgendwas bleibt dann doch hängen. Also.
Es gibt schon wirklich noch eine Menge Leute, die glaube ich so gar nicht jetzt aufn totalen Kriegskurs sind, sondern die einfach nur aus Faulheit.
Oder Verspultheit oder aus purem Unwissen heraus.
Irgendwie sich es nicht als notwendig äh angesehen haben, da schon mal einen Aktivitäts oder die einfach so viel arbeiten und so viel unterwegs sind und deren Leben nur aus Arbeit besteht.
Dass so zwei Stunden irgendwo ins Impfzentrum fahren, für die eine Investition ist.
Die sie so nicht in der Lage oder bereit sind zu zu tätigen.
Auch mal sehen, ne? Das ist einfach viele Leute auch in so prekären Arbeitssituationen gibt, wo wir halt sagen so, naja, gehst ja mal zum Impfzentrum, weißt du?
Noch einen Tag rum, ist eine Currywurst und so und das ist einfach manchmal für manche Leute auch einfach überhaupt keine Option. Da lassen sich vielleicht auch nochmal ein paar Prozent Gewinn.
Vor allem, wenn die Leute merken so, okay, alles klar, jetzt wird einfach der Druck, der gesellschaftliche Druck äh höher, weil es dann eben ein konkreter finanzieller Nachteil äh auch ist.
Wenn man nicht geimpft ist und die aber an sich jetzt so nichts gegen die Impfung haben oder zumindest nicht so viel dagegen haben, ist ihnen jetzt bis jetzt sich dagegen aufbäumen würden.
Ich glaub es.
Aber auch äh nach wie vor eine ähm eine Menge Leute, die wahrscheinlich schlichtweg verunsichert äh sind. Und äh,
Ich äh habe ja jetzt äh oder.
Vielleicht nicht nur ich, sondern viele durften ja vielleicht auch einen Blick so in die Anti-Wachser-Szene werfen im Zusammenhang mit dieser äh Pathologiekonferenz oder Pathologen Konferenz, wie auch immer. Ich weiß nicht, ob wir da.
Kommen wir gleich nochmal drauf, ja.
Ja. Ähm insofern äh so ja ähm,
Hm, ich, ich denke, dass äh dem muss man auch nach wie vor noch äh begegnen und nach wie vor auch noch aufklären und äh ja,
auch vor allem dieser Propaganda entgegentreten, aber dazu gleich noch.
Ja. Ja, man muss alles machen, ne? Und ich hab's ja vorhin schon gesagt. Wir haben halt auch immer noch diese Regelung mit irgendwie Auskunfts es gibt keine Auskunftspflicht und äh äh Firmen dürfen jetzt nicht,
erfahren, ob ihre Mitarbeiter geimpft sind oder nicht. Und da muss ich sagen.
Dass es ein schwieriges Feld, aber da bin ich eigentlich auch mal so ganz Team ähm Bevölkerungsschutz.
Das kann eigentlich nicht sein. Also das finde ich einfach ein völlig untragbaren Zustand. Gerade in Unternehmen, das ist ja im Prinzip Leute, die da reinkommen. Ich meine, du machst, machst du jetzt zwei Gehfisch ähdrei G fürs Stadion?
Ja oder eben zwei G fürs Stadion. Aber dein Büro, wo du jeden Tag aufs nächste.
Mit deinen anderen Mitarbeitern rumhängst und wo so ein Arbeitgeber dann auch irgendwie verantwortlich ist für die Gesundheit aller.
Da soll das dann irgendwie auf einmal nicht gehen. Also das das kriege ich irgendwie nicht so richtig in den Kopf.
Und wir haben das jetzt in den USA, da gibt's jetzt, was weiß ich hier, auch Microsoft und so, die sagen halt einfach, ja, nö, alle Mitarbeiter müssen jetzt geimpft sein, alle Gäste, die bei uns irgendwie auf den.
Fluren rumlaufen, die müssen geimpft sein, alle Geschäftspartner müssen geimpft sein, allerdings und das ist auch geil.
Es gibt eine Ausnahme, nämlich äh wenn der religiöse Gründe dagegen sprechen.
Ja und gesundheitliche äh das äh geht auch, aber da gibt's gibt's eigentlich kaum.
Bei Religion,
wird dann halt USA auch immer schnell schwierig, aber ich denke, das können wir jetzt auch mal skippen, weil das ist ja irgendwie äh nur die USA. Aber ich finde, in Deutschland sollte das einfach.
Auch so sein, dass die Unternehmen das einfach fordern können, im Prinzip den Zutritt zu ihren äh eigenen Räumen genauso handhaben können, wie das irgendwie äh Veranstaltungs jetzt machen müssen.
Gut, dann äh blicken wir dann nochmal kurz ins Schwubereich so zum äh Abschluss. Äh ich habe das gar nicht mitbekommen, weil ich eben unterwegs war. Ähm aber du hast dann so einen Twittertrend entdeckt.
Pathologiekonferenz. Bitte was ist das?
Ja
Ich wäre auch, wenn das nicht halt äh plötzlich so viel Aufmerksamkeit bekommen hätte, äh so wäre das wahrscheinlich auch an mir komplett äh vorbeigegangen, weil also im Endeffekt,
entpuppte sich das dann als äh äh Propagandaveranstaltung äh von ja,
Impfgegnern, die,
auch noch äh ja Partei äh äh Werbung für eine rechtsextreme Partei äh gemacht haben, sozusagen deren Name, die Deutsche Übersetzung von Al-Qaida ist, äh.
Ja. Ähm.
Weil ich wollte den Namen jetzt nicht direkt nennen und auch noch Werbung für die machen oder ja und.
Ist wirklich eine super Feststellung. Oh Mann, ja. Okay.
Ja.
So und ähm ja, ich habe mir dann tatsächlich die kompletten zweieinhalb Stunden äh Aufzeichnung
angetan, weil ähm so anders ging's nicht. Und äh so, also es macht die zusammen
Befassung so wäre ungefähr wir haben keine Beweise aber wir sehen da lauter Dinge die wir nicht verstehen und deswegen müssen wir sofort mit dem Impfen aufhören. Aber
und sagen das halt über zweieinhalb Stunden. So und am Anfang äh war's
eher noch äh so im im Rahmen. Also wenn man sich die ersten, ja, zwanzig, dreißig Minuten oder so anguckt, denkt man, okay, hm da ist jetzt so ein
pensionierter Pathologieprofessor, der hat jetzt äh mal ein paar.
Leute obduziert die nach der Impfung gestorben sind und hat da halt
nach seinen Aussagen halt äh völlig neue Krankheitsbilder gefunden und ganz seltene Krankheitsbilder und dann äh daraus geschlossen, dass die Hälfte.
Von zehn Leuten, die er da obduziert hat, ähm,
wahrscheinlich oder sehr wahrscheinlich ähm an der Impfung äh gestorben äh ist. So. Wobei er.
Feuer dann noch groß erzählte, na ja, um wirklich zu sagen, woran jemand gestorben ist, bräuchte man halt die äh eigentlich die ganzen klinischen Informationen und man müsste eigentlich sagen
dem Arzt äh und so und die Geschichte des Patienten kennen, um sich dann zu beklagen, dass die Dokumentation doch ganz miserabel sei und er die Dokumentation von den ganzen Patienten nicht habe, um
eben dann daraus zu schließen, äh dass äh äh ja äh sie wahrscheinlich oder sehr wahrscheinlich äh an der Impfung äh gestorben
äh sind und ähm das Ganze äh sieht halt erstmal ja,
Ich mein das sehen wir seriös aussehende, seriös daherredende Leute mit.
Verschiedenen Titeln, 'ne ganze Menge Mediziner, gut ein Elektrotechniker war auch noch dabei und bei einigen wusste man's nicht, was jetzt genau sind
aber den Eindruck, den das jetzt erstmal erweckte, war schon, dass das sagen so eine Veranstaltung ist von ja, vor allem
Medizinern, die von besorgten Medizinern, äh, sage ich mal so, die dann jetzt dort Beweise vorgelegt haben
und äh dann, wie gesagt, von diesem Pathologen war dann auch erstmal nur die Forderung.
Ähm ja, äh hier hier ist was, das sieht halt sehr beunruhigend aus und äh dem muss weiter,
nachgegangen werden und wir sollten mehr Obduktion äh machen. So. Sagen, ja okay
mit dem, ich sag mal, also mit dem wahrscheinlich oder sehr wahrscheinlich, da würde ich jetzt nicht unbedingt mitgehen, aber ich bin jetzt auch kein Pathologie Professor, wie gesagt, auch wenn das gewisse Logikschwächen
hatte und ich dem das nicht so abgenommen habe, aber gut, da kann man auch sagen, OK, das ist im,
da hat jemand einfach, da ist jemand besorgt und fordert, dass dem nachgegangen wird so. Aber,
Dann kam als nächstes irgendwie so ein Homöopathie-Arzt dran, der dann,
ähm ja einfach unglaublichen
Unsinn geschwurbelt hat, was selbst einigen der anderen, ich sage mal,
nicht ganz so unseriösen dann doch auch glaube ich fast gegen den Strich ging, aber den konnte man halt komplett abhaken, der hatte dann auch so ähm.
Wie äh Bilder, wo ich dann einfach äh gesagt hätte, die sind also die halte ich jetzt nicht für authentisch so, weil dann zeigte, ah, also so sieht das Blut aus,
vor der Impfung und dann irgendwie eine Woche nach der Impfung und zwei Wochen
nach der Impfung und das sah irgendwie alles ganz grässlich und verklumpt und furchtbar. Also ja, also lauter Bilder schon, wenn man die so sieht und äh die halt
ich mein so Medizinbilder und so und Ärzte die machen ja sowieso schon unter Umständen Angst oder bereiten Unbehagen, wenn man da so
im Prinzip Schnitte von Leichen sieht, das ist jetzt auch nicht jedermanns Sache, ja.
Und ähm dann äh da noch äh irgendwelche Ärzte oder Professoren hin und sagen, ja siehst du, das kommt, wenn man geimpft wird, ja? So
Also ähm ja, dann kam dieser irgendwie Homöopathie,
Arzt, der irgendwie komisch ist, komisch, das Zeugs äh äh erzählt hat und dann kam eine längere ähm.
Jetzt schon lachen. Äh eine Länge, Serie, wo sie Impfstoffe mikroskopiert äh haben
und dann merkwürdige Dinge in diesen Impfstoffen rumschwimmen, die so aussahen wie Chips und Antennen und äh ja, ich meine,
Bilder halt ja die Bilder halte ich jetzt für authentisch äh so, aber ich schätze, dass es halt für Kristalle äh äh gehalten, beziehungsweise in Medikamenten schwimmt halt.
Wohl immer alles mögliche Zeugs rum und wurden dann auch gefragt, ja haben sie sich denn auch mal die klassischen Impfstoffe
angeguckt, äh wie sehen die denn aus unter Mikroskop? Man sieht ja, die sehen halt ganz anders aus. Also diese Strukturen
und diese scharfkantigen irgendwie Dinge haben wir halt sonst nirgendwo gefunden.
Außer in einem anderen Impfstoff
Ja und sie haben's halt auch noch in jeder Charge gefunden, also jetzt bei den speziell bei den MRNA Impfstoffen, da war ich dann schon wieder äh erleichtert, dachte mir, okay, äh wenn das in jeder Charge drin ist, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit sehr groß
dass es da reingehört beziehungsweise schon da drin sein darf. Aber
nicht so, natürlich bei denen, sondern da war was. Sie konnten jetzt nicht genau sagen, um was es sich handelt. Es sah halt irgendwie nur
komisch aus. So und weil eben äh
ja, da Dinge drin sind, die komisch aussehen, von denen sie nicht sagen können, äh was es ist, ob's da reingehört
oder nicht und ob das in irgendeiner Weise gesundheitsschädlich ist, das konnten sie jetzt zwar nicht sagen
Aber äh äh deswegen müssen wir trotzdem sofort mit dem Impfen aufhören
Das war dann der Schluss, den sie dann aus den auch aus den Bildern
gezogen haben unter anderem. Ja und ich erinnerte mich da an so auch gewisse Ufovideos erinnert und auch diesen Mechanismus, okay, da sind Profis, die sehen was.
Was sie nicht verstehen, von dem sie nicht wissen, was es ist und ähm.
Ja äh sind halt beunruhigt und stecken mit ihrer Beunruhigung anderer an und äh ja ähm.
Sind denn das für Vögel? Also ich meine ein Elektrotechniker hat ja dann irgendwie die Antennen dann auch gleich ausgebaut und mit.
Also zu den Antennen gar nichts, das kam irgendwie von der Ärztin. Äh also die haben jetzt äh beziehungsweise ein Arzt meinte dann noch, sie hätten jetzt auch bei Geimpften festgestellt, äh dass die halt
spezielle elektromagnetische Strahlung imitieren. Ähm
dachte ich mir nur wow super, wir können uns ja das mit dem digitalen Impfausweisen Impfnachweisen völlig,
sparen, dann äh machen wir demnächst äh einfach nur ein Radioempfänger und den musst du dann nur an jemanden dran halten und dann weißt du halt, ob er geimpft ist, oder ist doch ist doch super
ähm ja.
Ich wundere mich nur, weil weil dieser
Herr Bergholz, wie er heißt hier irgendwie auf dieser Webseite von dieser Veranstaltung ja einer von den drei Protagonisten ist, die da äh an diesem Tisch saßen. Na ja, hier steht halt, hier ist ehemaliger Professor für Elektrotechnik mit Schwerpunkt Qualitäts- und Risikomanage
An der Jakobs University Bremen, was auch immer das ist.
Ja, ja, aber wer hat, der hat, glaube ich, nicht, der hat nicht viel erzählt. Äh.
Okay, aber immerhin, also ich meine, er war vor seiner Berufung 17 Jahre im Management Digitalproduktion tätig.
Voll der Experte. Mhm.
Aber also sie haben jetzt äh sozusagen die die Chips, die sie da gezeigt haben, also für mich sah das aus äh hatte ungefähr so die die Dimension eines iPhones bloß in klein
so also im Prinzip.
Die haben ernsthaft behauptet, es würde sich dabei um Chips handeln.
Und äh sie haben das Chips genannt, aber sie haben jetzt nicht behauptet, es wären Mikrochips, ich meine, das hätte man halt ganz einfach lösen können, indem man dann mitm,
oder so draufguckt, indem man das dann da rausholt und mit einem richtigen Mikroskop draufguckt.
Irgendwelche Strukturen drin sind. Stattdessen haben sie dann irgendwie ein äh angeblich diesen Kristall, der da zu sehen war, dann äh oder diesen Chip
rausgezogen und trocknen lassen und dann sah es halt aus wie 'nen
äh Kristall, der auch noch eine ganz andere Form äh hatte. Also für mich waren das also, ich hätte spontan gesagt, das sind Kristalle und dann war da noch etwas, das sah so ein bisschen aus wie.
Sagen, mikrofluidische Strukturen oder irgendwelche ähm,
Strukturen, die so für mich aussahen, als wenn die durch irgendwelche Strömungs
Ereignisse irgendwie geformt worden wären. Wie gesagt, alles so im Mikrometer
Bereich des Ganze, also hatten irgendwie ein optisches Mikroskop mit zweitausendfacher Vergrößerung und.
Ich meine, wenn wenn das jetzt ein seriöses Trio da wäre, ja und sie wird dich da irgendwie konkrete Feinings hätten.
Dann schreibt man an Paper da drüber und dann gibt man das in die Wissenschaftscommunity und dann wird das Review und dann kann man das irgendwie überprüfen. Äh setzt man sich nicht in so ein, so ein, so ein komische Konferenzsituation, zeigt irgendwelche bunten Bilder und sagt, du, ja, wir wissen ja auch nicht genau, was das ist, aber unserer Meinung ist es das.
Ja.
Genau. Und ich war auch fast äh meinte die diese eine Ärztin, ich weiß nicht, ob sie wirklich äh die Wahrheit per Zoom irgendwie dazugeschaltet, aber angeblich Ärztin ähm hm.
Meinte dann, als es dann darum ging, so mit der Elektromagnetischen Strahlung, ja, sie wollten halt jetzt auch mal gucken, was passiert, wenn sie denn die Impfstoffe dann äh irgendwie WLAN-Strahlung aussetzen.
Oh Gott, ey.
Na ja äh ich meine gut.
WLAN-Strahlung, ja?
Okay. Kleine Information jedem Impfzentrum wird werden alle Impfstoffe die ganze Zeit fehlers Strahlung ausgesetzt. Hey Leute, mit ihren Smartphones daneben sitzen. Oh Mann, ey.
Mhm. Ja. Ach so und dann wollten sie noch gucken, dann war noch ein Vorschlag, äh ob sie halt dann Geimpfte quasi in einen VHD schon Käfig mal bringen und gucken, ob dann immer noch diese Elektromagnetische Strahlung aus ihnen rauskommt.
Oh Gott, ey.
Ich meine, ich meine gut, wahrscheinlich, also theoretisch möglich wär's, so,
vielleicht ein bisschen also man könnte tatsächlich Chips äh äh bauen, die ungefähr in den Dimensionen liegen, die ähm sich entweder chemisch oder äh,
per elektromagnetischen Wellen ihre Energie
Haarwesten und äh dann so, ja, irgendwelche schon Kommunikations oder Sensoraufgaben oder so äh übernehmen. Nur
natürlich die Frage.
Wenn das jetzt wirklich Chips wären äh so, äh was machen die denn dann? Äh sonst noch? So.
Oder was was soll die denn? Ja, egal, auf jeden Fall war das also, wie gesagt, das waren halt.
Verunreinigungen, äh die aber wohl äh so wie ich das dann äh äh mitbekommen habe in Arzneimitteln, nicht ungewöhnlich sind und äh auch
es auch nicht RNA Impfstoffe gibt, wo man vergleichbare Strukturen findet. Ja, aber,
wie gesagt wenn man da jetzt so eben,
nur mit den naturwissenschaftlichen Grundkenntnissen eines Arztes jetzt rangeht oder Ärztin in dem
Fall äh so, dann äh ja äh ich meine, kann man sich nur vorstellen, dass jetzt so normale Leute, also ich weiß nicht, wenn meine Mutter das jetzt sehen würde oder so
lauter Professoren und Ärzte, die da sitzen und äh irgendwie diese furchtbaren Bilder äh zeigen und dann den Impfstoff fordern, so.
Ja, ich ich wäre schon besorgt, ja, wenn ich wenn ich da jetzt keinen Kontext hätte, gut, sie würde dann mich anrufen, wahrscheinlich und mich dann fragen, was ist denn das? Äh aber äh ja
also muss sagen, ich war äh tatsächlich äh so schon ein wenig entsetzt von äh ja wie potenziell doch effektive
Angstpropaganda sie da nicht nur zusammengebracht haben sondern wie viel Aufmerksamkeit sie auch dafür.
Haben und ähm insofern äh ja gut
I mein, wenn sie jetzt wirklich gut gewesen wären, dann hätten sie halt äh einigen von dem Quatsch weggelassen äh so, dann wäre das Ganze wahrscheinlich viel effizienter
äh oder effektiver gewesen, aber irgendwann, wie gesagt, ging's dann halt einfach auch äh einfach over the top.
So, wenn man jedenfalls sich ein bisschen auskennt, ein bisschen Ahnung hat oder ein bisschen mitdenkt und ein bisschen halt dann Logik äh,
irgendwie mal auf den oder ihr
auf den Prüfstand stellt oder ihre Argumentationskette braucht man selbst vom Fach nichts zu wissen, wenn man einfach nur, ich sage mal, äh deutsch und Logik kann, kann man auch äh dahinter kommen, dass die halt ziemlich viel Unsinn erzählen. Aber
ähm.
Das liegt nicht jedem.
Ne und äh wie gesagt, und,
wenn und ich muss sagen, nachdem ich das gesehen habe, äh so ähm bin ich auch ein bisschen vorsichtiger geworden so, manchen Leuten wirklich vorzuwerfen
dass die halt Angst vor der Impfung haben, sondern wenn du sagst nicht da nicht gefestigt bist oder nicht
irgendwie keine Ahnung hast und das und so eine Inszenierung siehst äh so, ich mein ganz offensichtlich
wirkt die sogar auf Mediziner, ja? Und insofern, ja,
muss man ihm echt entgegen treten und dann wurd's glaub ich auf YouTube auch noch,
das äh Video äh so, aber es ist halt trotzdem, wenn ich sowohl bei denen auf der Seite verfügbar als auch äh so einige, ja äh Presse das, denke mal, hieß es natürlich, Zensur und die Wahrheit wird unterdrückt.
Weil die Regierung befürchtet irgendwie Schadenersatzforderungen, wenn rauskommt,
irgendwie das jetzt weiß ich nicht 20 Prozent der Leute schwere Gesundheitsschäden davon tragen so und da hab ich dann nur so ich sag mal als vielleicht auch als Beruhigung.
Ähm ähm,
die funktioniert vielleicht nicht für jeden, aber wahrscheinlich so für 99,9Prozent sich einfach mal zu überlegen, okay.
Wie viel Leute kenne ich, die sich infiziert haben und äh was waren so deren Erfahrungsberichte und die gehen halt von, naja, irgendwie einen Schnupfen über mh krasse Scheiße bis tot.
So jetzt in meinem direkten Umfeld.
So, also direkt äh sozusagen ungefilterte, nicht nicht medial vermittelte Erfahrung, so
und wenn ich mir dann gucke, was ist mit den Geimpften in meiner Umgebung? Da sind mittlerweile, ich kenne, glaube ich, gar keinen Ungeimpften mehr. Ähm.
Ich leider schon.
Äh also mir fällt im Moment im Moment jedenfalls keiner ein
und äh mit anderen Worten so eigentlich fast alle Leute, die ich kenne, sind geimpft und äh da war äh das Schlimmste, von dem mir jemand berichtet hatte, naja, er war halt äh.
Drei Tage ganz schön im Eimer und hatte Fieber. So. Das war, ich meine,
Ich will damit jetzt nicht äh auch in Abrede stellen, dass es nicht.
Auch Leute gibt, mit äh die schwere Impfschäden davontragen, dass es nicht auch Leute gibt, die äh aufgrund äh der Impfung sterben so, aber ähm,
selbst wenn ich den offiziellen Zahlen nicht traue, ähm so ähm.
Muss ich sagen, das kann jeder selber, sage ich mal, für sich machen
wie das in seiner Umgebung aussieht, ist sagen für mich und auch jeder, mit dem ich dem ich geredet habe zumindest äh in, also in meiner so sterben die Leute
nicht an der Impfung oder erleiden schwere Gesundheitsschäden
Das ist natürlich auch nur anekdotische Evidenz, aber sie passt zu den offiziellen Zahlen, im Gegensatz zu äh den Zahlen
von diesen Pathologen und wer da sonst.
Haben. Das ist echt alles übertrieben. Ja, nee. Also, ich glaube, wir haben auch äh unter unseren Hörern wahrscheinlich keine Ungeimpften mehr, kann ich mir irgendwie ehrlich gesagt nicht so richtig vorstellen. Ich habe jetzt übrigens auch die ganze Familie durchgeimpft bekommen.
Ja, meine Tochter hatte sich jetzt auch letzte Woche ihre Zweitimpfung abgeholt.
Von daher erstmal aus dem roten Bereich raus, aber ja, da sollten auch alle anderen auch folgen.
Gut Pavel. Ich denke, wir können äh die Sendung zu Ende tragen. Hm.
Oh, schon. Es kam mir so kurz vor.
Na ja,
meine Stunde 40 haben wir jetzt schon zusammen irgendwie, aber ist jetzt äh gibt auch gar nicht so viel zu besprechen. Zumindest haben wir jetzt erstmal wieder so ein bisschen die ähm aktuelle Lage erfasst und wir müssen mal gucken. Ich bin jetzt in der nächsten Zeit
nochmal viel unterwegs. Deswegen äh seht es mir nach, dass wir hier äh gerade den Wochentakt noch nicht ganz wieder aufnehmen können.
Es ist ja auch äh alles grade äh etwas weniger erregt. Von daher wäre ich auch schon ganz froh, wenn wir erstmal äh auf BIY Week League äh kommen.
Ähm das könnte sich durchaus ergeben. Ja und dann schauen wir einfach mal weiter. Ähm.
Können ja auch alternativ äh mal wieder eine äh Clubhausrunde einberufen, aber da haben wir jetzt noch keinen Termin festgelegt.
Ja, das das wär wäre vielleicht auch ganz ganz gut, weil das hilft ja auch dann sagen,
äh wieder äh zum einen mitzubekommen, äh welche Themen äh die Leute interessieren plus neue Informationen so von der von der Front und ähm.
Haben wir uns jetzt aber noch nicht über einen äh Termin abgestimmt, deswegen kann ich jetzt auch gerade keinen sagen und da ich äh grade sehr viel Reiseplanung habe, ist das auch alles ein bisschen haarig.
Aber werden wir machen und ähm ja, genau. Vielleicht an der Stelle nochmal der Hinweis. Ihr könnt uns natürlich auf Twitter folgen. Pavel, Pavel, äh Pavel dreiundzwanzig, ich, Tim Pritla
und äh außerdem die Metaebenebene.
Da kommunizieren wir so was eigentlich immer, wenn's ähm das gibt und ja, das ist der beste Weg auch für Feedback abgesehen jetzt natürlich von den Kommentaren zu dieser Sendung. Wenn ihr da welche habt, dann bitte hinein damit.
Ja, sonst noch was.
Nichts mehr ein.
Mehr haben wir erstmal nicht.
Also vielen Dank, vielen Dank auch für äh alle Spenden, alle Unterstützung, alle äh Kommentare und äh äh sonstigen Tipps und Hinweise, keep it coming. Und wir hören uns dann demnächst bald wieder, äh wenn's heißt, Corona-Wikli. Wir sagen tschüss.